number one
the first one
alone
it's just to show you how to leave
is
[Music]
we're calm over here
[Music]
so excuse me so
he said that i can sit and wait if i
wanted to
you know
after they say people might be asking
questions or whatever
they won't be asking me questions
then i can get off guard
no they there's gonna be a roving knife
um
once you get through today
john can you just see what gerald i
think geraldine's got a query about
mike's
[Music]
well spotted
[Music]
literally it's not a good room that is
it
doesn't work okay we need to get started
which can be a good thing
yeah it's tricky
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please be
upstanding in order to receive the
worship call from there
good evening ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to this meeting of council
please be seated
father gerald murphy was going to lead
us in prayer this evening before we
begin our meeting but unfortunately he's
not been able to make it so
he does send his apologies and
i'll go on to apologies and i've
received apologies of absence from
councillors chilton jarman
jerome and whittam and councillor myers
and also the leader of the council
council andrew weston
and councillor oxford have had to give
their apologies because of the need to
self-isolate
can i ask if anyone is aware of any
other apologies
counselor gilbert thank you any others
okay as we are holding our meeting here
at ua 92
we do not have our normal voting
facilities
so any votes this evening will be by a
show of hands
this meeting is also being streamed live
on the council's committee meetings
youtube channel the whole of the meeting
will be recorded
except where there are confidential or
exempt
items and this activity promotes
democratic engagement
in accordance with section 100a of the
local government's act 1972
you will have noted the amount of
business that we have before us this
evening
so in the lead up to the meeting we have
canvassed the groups to identify
potential speakers on each of the items
therefore as i open the debate on each
item first of all
i will invite those members who have
been given prior notice
of their who have given prior notice of
their intention to speak
to make their speech other members may
indicate that they wish to speak
but i would ask you to avoid repetition
please note that all at all times that
it may be necessary to
reduce the times for speeches so that we
can complete the business this evening
due to it being a busy meeting until our
time to
for more debate on some of the main
items the green party group have
indicated
that they wish to defer their motion on
universal basic income
trial to the next meeting so may i ask
council
if this if it consents to this
hi thank you the first item is minutes
and i move that the minutes of the
annual meet council meeting
held on the 26th of may 2021
be taken as read as a signed
correct record is that seconded seconded
thank you thank you all in favor
hi item two announcements her majesty
the queen's
birthday honours may we take this
opportunity to recognize those citizens
and persons
connected with trafford who were named
on her majesty the queen's birthday
honours list
mrs fans francis mccarran of altringham
was awarded the obe
for services to education
of stratford was awarded the obe for
services
to faith communities mr john shiels
of sale was awarded the mbe for services
to young people
through football and mr abdul
javis of warburton was awarded the mbe
for services
to the nhs particularly during covert
19.
also of note tony lloyd mp a former
member of council
had received a knighthood and teresa
grant former chief executive
was awarded an obe i am sure you will
join with me
in conveying the council's
congratulations for their achievements
and richly deserved recognition
does the deputy leader of the council
wish to make any announcements this
evening
um yes please um just very briefly
members will likely be aware of the
incident um this afternoon
at trafford general um just to
to note really that council is
supporting
the nhs um and the police
and that our thoughts are obviously with
those that have been
affected thank you thank you deputy
leader
do the chairs of scrutiny committees
have anything to announce on behalf of
their committees
thank you councillor dr barclay she's
here
thank you very much i had some three
questions
i can advise that seven questions have
been submitted
for this evening and that they have been
listed on the council's website
for members of the public to view i have
been advised that on this occasion
i would ask council to note that due to
the number of substantial
and significant items and motions before
us this evening
and to allow the council to devote more
time to those items
the questions will not be read out this
evening and in accordance with procedure
rules
full written answers will be provided to
the questionnaires at a later date
and will also be published on the
council's website
thank you item 4
is a petition regarding a 20 mile per
hour zone
for safer streets in north altringham
which received
513 signatures in accordance with the
council's petition scheme
the petition organiser mrs de la torre
will be invited to speak to the petition
for five minutes
following which it will be debated by
council for a maximum
of 15 minutes as it is
the agreed practice for petitions at
council speeches are normally limited to
one member
from each of the groups and since there
is only 15 minutes allowed for the
debate
it reached
i've lost my thread for the debate each
group will be allocated 3 minutes and 45
seconds
following the debate the deputy leader
of the council will then summarise the
council's response
if council consents to these
arrangements i will now invite ms de la
torre to introduce the petition
mr lator mr
so we've got those the wrong way around
possibly actually
yes so
it's mrs stanker mrs stanley thank you
you're going to speak to this petition
yes please would you like to speak okay
good evening everybody
my decision to put forward a petition
for 20 mile an hour zones in the
following roads
is to improve safety for children
walking around and playing in the
streets
because it's a built up a residential
area
brunswick road bridgewater road newton
road
wharf road gasco road hazel road
grosvenor road sandy way road and the
a56 which is manchester road
now where i live there are a number of
blind spots
these have a low visibility for the
driver
this increases in the winter months due
to low reduced street lighting on the
roads
the first blind spot is on the wharf
road turning
in from navigation road into and
reverse on bridgewater road due to a
section of footpath jutting out
and parked cars causing the driver to
drive on the wrong side of the road
and this could cause a collision if not
if they're not aware also on wharf road
a new development of 99 apartments
and on bridgewater road nine town houses
will increase the volume of traffic
there's been a further new development
at the end of bridgewater road
also increasing the volume of traffic
this corner of bridgewater road creates
a second blind spot
drivers cut the corner onto newton road
and on
oncoming traffic are on the in the
middle of the road
due to parked cars on their left
hand side resulting in near-misses
third blind spot as you turn onto
brunswick road from newton road
brunswick road is a long straight road
where some drivers tend to build up
speed
unaware there are a couple of side roads
which is chevron's
place and bryan avenue
now the fourth blind spot is at the top
of brunswick road
towards navigation road now where
there's a slowed down
children playing signage has been
erected now whether that's been erected
by
the council or a private person i don't
know
these residential roads are built up
with a parking on both sides of the
street
as poor visibility to the drivers
pedestrians
if they step out between parked cars
especially children and pets
if drivers are not made aware
more couriers supermarket deliveries due
to online shopping
taking place there's more uh vehicles
going up and down that road
hdv vehicles are delivering materials to
the work sites
of the new developments and at the
moment for 10 days they've had to close
um only for access only uh
newton road and bridgewater road i think
it is to allow
you know the developments to on go with
the uh
the work that they're doing um a lower
speed
enables a driver to have a quicker
response to reducing
accidents and fatal injuries navigation
school on gasco road
and gladstone road has increased the
number of entries
for more children from a wider area to
attend
this increases the volume of traffic and
parents dropping
and collecting their children daily
again
school patrol lights would slow traffic
down
the headmistress has requested parents
to walk their children
so safety measures put in force to slow
down the traffic
all pedestrians young and elderly should
feel safe to walk and not to feel
a car losing control through going over
the speed limit
could mount the curb as a pedestrian
experience pinning them
to a wall causing them injuries
drivers who travel at high speed higher
speeds
have less time to identify and read what
is happening around them
it takes them longer to react
let's not wait for accidents to happen
let's create
safer roads the department of transport
advised traffic authorities to keep the
speed limits
under review with changing circumstances
and consider the introduction of
more 20 mile per hour zones and limits
in built up areas that are primarily
residential
we've achieved 513 signatures from
people supporting this
as i read a paper newspaper clipping
schools top of list
for 20 mile per hour zones rose outside
schools will be prioritized for 20 mile
per hour zones across trafford
and residents can request zones in their
area
traffic council has announced it is
going to push
for low-speed zones across the borough
and will prioritize roads outside
schools
parks and residential homes first
residents will be able to request that
roads in their
area are limited to 20 miles per hour
but must meet a set of criteria to be
eligible
and the new criteria were set out in the
report
brought to traffic council's executive
meeting
roads are more likely to be prioritized
for a new 20 mile
per hour limit if any of the following
apply
initially and they are these are high
levels of
of on street parking a school
is on the road there is a history of
fatal
serious slight collisions on the road
there are community centers places of
worship
bus tram stops local shops nurseries
nursing homes
on the road there is good community
support for
20 miles i don't want to interrupt you
but you
you come to your end of your time can
you just um okay so
let's consider this seriously let's get
safer roads
let's slow down the traffic let
pedestrians feel safe
walking and especially at night time
we've got low lighting now
reduced lighting so please all i can say
is
let's consider this thank you mr
priority
thank you and councillor adzad as the
executive member for environmental and
regulatory services
i invite you now to respond on behalf of
the labour group
thank you yes sir i'm quite pleased to
obviously see
the residents here come with this
petition tonight and it's quite timely
as has
been indicated it was only some time
last month
uh when we took a report to executive
actually on the
20 zones as you may know the last time
we did any sort of 20 zones was in the
90s and 90s
and we had special government funding i
mean did they be large scale schemes
that you see all down the borough
and there's many areas have them but
obviously not all areas took them up at
that time
and since then that particular pots of
funding have actually gone so i was
concerned obviously
i did set up a couple years ago a group
safety round schools group and
the idea was to actually look at all
aspects of safety around the schools
taking account everything
and this was a one of the pieces of work
that we've just achieved recently it's
taken a little while to get there
but to get all the assessments done and
everything has been taken quite a bit of
time
so it's obviously it does as is
indicated uh it does indicate
uh priorities for where there are things
like schools early personal and things
like that so they'll get the highest
number of points
in that scoring system people could have
requested one before
we introduced this report but the
problem was it was mixed in our top with
all the other requests for things like
yellow lines
and other things like that and whilst a
lot of these things were quite important
i think we wanted to set out very
clearly
that areas like where they're
particularly schools the only person's
homes perhaps parks something like
so we thought that that should be a
particular uh criteria of its own and
they should be judged actually on their
own merit
so we set all this uh all together in a
policy now and that's gone through in
june now so
all these schemes and i've seen actually
you're not the first to do this request
by the way i've actually seen quite a
lot already
so i think it's going to be very popular
during the year so obviously uh we're
not going to be able to do every single
request without the borrower
unfortunately so the cry2 actually
helped juice those and as you indicated
ones with schools and it will actually
have the highest priority within that so
i'm quite pleased
they printed that and obviously i know i
know uh council welton actually sent me
information this over the weekend and
that's actually gone off
too uh onto the uh traffic team now to
look at
and and the report will come back to say
it's been processed and where it sits
within the table of that and during the
course of the year
all these uh requests are added together
then towards the end of the year when we
start putting in the capital programme
for the following year
they're all then looked at and
prioritized and they all come out in the
mix and we see which ones to score the
highest
and and then obviously we can put those
into the capital program for next year
so hopefully with that i'm pleased that
we can take issues like this safety
and particularly safety around schools
is something that we want to prioritize
and it's the purpose of said why i set
up the group particularly look at those
sort of areas and we found it the
highest importance
and quite pleased to see that this is
one of the first to actually be able to
sort of see
it going into the mix and obviously i
welcome that so thank you with that i'll
leave it at that thank you
thank you councillor i'd said and
councillor morgan's going to respond on
behalf of the conservative group
thank you mr mayor um firstly i'd like
to say congratulations to petitioners
for all their work
um organizing this petition and bringing
it in front of us um i think it's an
excellent example of the petition
process bringing important matters to
this chamber
um we are absolutely behind this
petition and would encourage the labour
executive to implement it as soon as
feasible
and it's an example of where we should
be definitely implementing a 20 mile an
hour zone
as defined boundaries it's an entirely
residential area
in addition it has a popular primary
school where large numbers of children
walk to school each day
their safety should be one of our
primary concerns as a council
i look forward to welcoming further
petitions to this council
as there are a lot of areas both my own
ward and the wider borough which will
benefit from them
however if mr mayor doesn't mind my
indulgence i'm going to just
use a bit of my time to ask this labour
executive to go a bit further
the recent report approved by executive
was to say a little bit disappointing
my police council at adset is to be bold
on this issue
and to get ahead of the petitions before
they come to this council thank you
thank you councillor morgan and i invite
councillor brophy to respond on behalf
of the liberal democratic group
thank you mr mayor so firstly i'd just
like to congratulate the residents for
producing this petition and especially
to mrs tanker for
attending full council and presenting
some of you may remember that the
original 20 miles per hour motion was a
liberal democrat motion supported by
labour
and i'd just like to say a few words
about why 20 miles per hour is so
important
and it does make our streets safer i
know the area that mrs stanker outlined
is very well quite near to where i live
i look mostly as a cyclist or a
pedestrian
and it definitely will improve safety in
that area just to reiterate the figures
that
if you're going 20 miles per hour as
pedestrian has got a 97
chance of survival that reduces to 92
percent
if you're going 30 miles per hour so
just that 10
mile per hour difference can make a big
difference to the outcome
and it's very important we look at this
for all our urban areas it should be a
national standard
it's better for the environment less
pollution at a lower speed
and it's particularly more pleasant for
pedestrians especially those who are
elderly
or perhaps with young children disabled
people with prams or push chairs
it makes the area quieter makes people
feel safer
particularly for walkers and cyclists
and it also
improves traffic flow and so on behalf
of the liberal democrat group
welcome the petition very much and uh
thank you again to the residents for
bringing this forward and we
wholeheartedly support it
thank you mr mayor thank you councillor
brophy and councillor welton for the
green party please
thank you very much mr mayor um i have
to declare an interest and i'll declare
council morgan's interest
in this petition because we both live in
the area of the petition so we are
particularly passionate
about this one i want to thank elaine
for uh for gathering the um
the signatures on the petition um and i
believe it was the very first petition
that was purely on the council website
that achieved 500 signatures so that's
pretty impressive in a pandemic
when you can't go door to door and raise
petitions i think it shows how
you know and it's not a huge area this
area but it's been signed by a lot of
people and a lot of people who live
actually directly in the area and that
just shows how strongly this is
this is held but we also have um 20
miler now petitions for about 75 percent
of our award now and i know that there's
several under on on the
trafford petition site for other areas
around trafford
so what's going to happen is that we're
just going to have a big queue of 20
mile an hour petitions
of which only one two three how many i
don't know
just going to be actioned every year and
everyone else is going to be on the back
burner
and this is because the administration
is afraid
to bring forward the
20 mile an hour limits on all
residential roads
on all shopping streets as they should
be
across the borough now stockport have
just
announced that they are going to be
having 20 mile an hour limits on all
their residential roads
stockport just down the road why are we
letting them
get ahead of us in this why aren't we
doing this
the whole of wales will have 20 mile an
hour zones on its residential streets
by 2023 go down to london
everywhere is 20 mile an hour zones go
over to within shore
drive down princess parkway you'll find
it virtually every single road off there
is 20 miles an hour we're so far behind
the curve on this it's ridiculous and
it's going to get worse
what we're doing now is we're getting
everybody excited about 20 miles an hour
because we know it's a good thing to do
but we're not providing we're not
providing the opportunities
for it to happen we're just going to end
up with a big queue which is going to
result in people like elaine
people like councillor morgan people
like myself being extremely unhappy
um unless we get ahead we know it can't
be done overnight
but three years five years even
set an objective show some ambition say
we're going to do this in this time
and then we'll try and get there
together thank you
thank you councillor welton um
councillor hines deputy leader
will respond yes thank you
matt um so i too would like to
add my thanks to mrs stanker and to the
residents for bringing
this petition to us tonight and we very
much do welcome
um the suggestions that you've made
and i don't want to get too political in
this
meeting because you've brought this
petition to us and i think it's really
important that we respond to your
petition
um we are being bold in our approach to
20 mile an hour zones
more bold than um the previous
administration
ever were who didn't have a policy on
this
um and didn't support it when we brought
it to
council um so it is um the ambition
of the uh of the administration and the
executive i think mrs stanker actually
summed up
um the position of the executive really
really well
um the suggestions that you've made will
be
um considered in line with um our
policies
um and we will certainly look at what
you've suggested
we do welcome what you suggested um and
as councillor ad said
articulated um then those proposals
um will be put forward against our
capital
programme so um i'd really like to thank
you for bringing those
um tonight thank you thank you council
hines
um item five and we have a second
petition regarding stop signage
on woodburn road in sale which received
597
signatures again with the arrangements
for dealing with the petitions
i now i will now invite mrs de la tour
to introduce
the petition mrs dela talk thank you
um so this petition was raised as a
result of an accident that occurred
in april and two cars collided
at the junction with woodburn road and
framingham road
it was awful i saw it and one car ended
up on its side with a mum and a son
trapped and there was also a child in
the other car
this is the third accident of this
nature that i can recall
in the past couple of years prior to
that um to the accident in april there
was an accident in december
a car ended up mounting the pavement and
crashing into a wall
um where the lollipop lady stands
thankfully she wasn't there it was just
before
school time um well sorry it was before
three o'clock
and the nature of these last three
accidents are drivers leaving woodburn
at sorry brooklyn's road
traveling towards framingham road and
they're not stopping at the junction
and two of them have happened in
daylight and there's been good
visibility
markings have been refreshed which can
only be a good thing but it appears that
drivers are simply not aware
that it's a junction irrespective of
markings or signage
um it's an urban junction approached in
four directions via straight roads and
unfortunately this is attracting
speeding
there's over houses
that have to use that junction as their
only access point
um there's brooklyn's primary school
that is two houses down from the
junction
again you've got to use the junction to
get to and from the school
and obviously that generates a lot of
pedestrian and vehicle traffic
and there's a sports field at the end of
woodbourne road that draws people from
outside of the area as well who may not
be
familiar with the with the road network
there's over 400 properties off
framingham road
and the surrounding areas many of which
use that juncture's
the junction as an access point um
and a lot of people stand on the corner
as well it seems to be like a meeting
place or you know
waiting for a lift um
now the position was originally created
to campaign for the installation of a
stop sign
um and it's clear from the strength of
response from the residents
that there's a lot of support for this
we've got 597
signatures and in light of gmp
not supporting the stop sign but the
strength of the response
it's clear that something needs to be
done to improve the safety you know this
junction
limit traffic and speed um
at the minute there were a few measures
to curb speeding
and as a resident that lives really
quite close to the junction
i witnessed speeding on a on a on a
daily basis you know that's
the speeds that i see are terrifying
they're really hot
um if it's possible to slow down
vehicles and get
again it's a 20 mile an hour you know it
we desperately need it
because i think it'd have a massive
impact on the safety of the junction
and the issues that we're having there i
do feel it's only a matter of time
unfortunately before there is yet
another accident at the junction
and i'm really fearful that the
consequences could be a lot more severe
and yeah if something needs to be done
about the the safety there of that
junction and our
narrow roads yeah thank you thank you
mrs dillator
um councillor ad said again as a
relevant
executive member i invite you now to
respond on behalf of the labour group
thank you for being in this position
here tonight and honestly i'm quite
pleased
when you've sent it you told us i've
actually seen quite a lot of
correspondence from council london
uh i'm not sure your lady was actually
corresponding with or not
but yeah so i've seen all the emails
between yourselves and council i know
council long's been very much involved
with it so
i'd like to thank council london as well
uh this because i don't know whether
he's able to speak so i can see his
behalf i know he's been very active in
this support in the residence
so it's obviously quite pleasing
obviously quite please obviously you've
got a lot of signatures there and
obviously residents do feel very
strongly
uh i've been involved in highways
committee since it's been on the council
a long time ago so
during that time and say that uh we've
always taken road safety seriously in
that time
and i think it's it's paramount that we
try and do everything that we can
one as you well aware obviously we have
had extensive discussions with both the
police
and the highway engineers and they said
unfortunately that stopped sign itself
that it does not conform to the dft
regulation and the police aren't
supportive of that but i know from
speaking with the police
and our own traffic teams have had
discussions myself i suppose as well as
corresponding with council london and
i've seen all the messages from myself
as well
that we actually try and do lots of
things to actually try and improve that
safety
obviously know already that they've
actually improved the
advanced giveaway markings with a
backing board and so forth to highlight
it much more clearer
and they've also repainted all the
airlines and i think you indicated that
yourself down there
and obviously it isn't going to stop
there though it's obviously going to be
a review
of all the waiting restrictions in the
area now as part of that review
i'm sure yourselves and council london
will be able to see if you think there's
other things we can look at during that
process
that may actually uh help with that and
assist with that obviously i'd quite
welcome that and i'm sure
that yourself will be able to discuss
that along with the other councils there
so we can actually see
as what other measures can we do around
there so it's just unfortunate that uh
these stop signs the debbie prescribed
in dfc guidelines and it's really
hamstrung that we can't we really cannot
implement it and the police eventually
simply said
it not supports what the police will
actually support in actually reviewing
the whole junction
and so our traffic engine so it's
something we really want to do and going
but obviously and i'd ask you to
continue to raise with us and any of our
ideas you can come up with we'll
actually happily look at thank you
thank you councillor answered um the
deputy mayor councillor boys is going to
respond on behalf of the conservative
group
yes uh thank you mr mayor um
and thank you to the over 550 residents
who have signed this petition i think
probably about 150 as a result of me
pursuing social media i must say i live
within 300 yards of this junction
and at the outset i have to stay i am
totally in favor of the petition
um i'm sorry if i'm going to repeat just
a couple of things but i won't take too
much of your time
this is brought to council by residents
in my ward and is presented as you've
heard as a direct result
of a second if not a third appalling
accident
at the woodbourne road framingham road
junction it is actually only by
chance due to being delayed at school
that the school patrol crossing lady was
not in place when the first
happened thankfully so otherwise she
might have suffered severe
injury or even worse the road surface
signage has now been repainted
but when traveling east along woodbourne
road
the current giveaway sign still remains
in part concealed by a significantly
large
tree reference gmp's comments
given that a very similar situation
there are stop signs at the junction of
temple road
and broad road close to malden's junior
school
and the cherubs day nursery and i can
see absolutely no reason
why stop signs should not be placed at
this potentially
very very dangerous junction thank you
mr mayor
thank you councillor boys um councillor
new grosh
please can you respond on behalf of the
liberal democrat group
thank you
i'd like to thank residents for their
597 signatures of this
petition i briefly like to speak in
support of it
this petition uh directly affects my
residence on framingham
and it's a shame that such a dangerous
junction with a history of collisions
such as woodbourne and framingham
requires a petition to bring it to the
council's attention
and we'd like to support this and all
the safety measures required to bring it
up to specification
thank you thank you councillor new grosh
um councillor welton would you like to
speak for the green party please
thank you very much uh i think the uh
council had said the executive member
was
looking for some suggestions so without
wanting to sound like a busted flush
give him a 20 mile an hour zone i think
uh around there might help
things um and uh a school street
perhaps given that the school as we know
is two
doors down from this junction you know
it's been a long time this
administration's been in office
for several years now and school streets
have been talked about a lot
but nothing has happened yet when are we
going to start getting some delivery
we we also i'll tell you where the
what's happening with the delivery is
the fact that one traffic haven't got
anybody in the highways team
to actually design the schemes at the
moment if you look at the job
adverts for hype for the trafford
one traffic highways team they're
advertising for pretty much everyone
from basic engineers to chief um
chief designers and chief engineers i
don't know what's happening in there
maybe it's the lack of support that they
got last year when
the controversial schemes from the
emergency active travel fund
were were were being fought over so hard
um several people i believe have left
since then
um but in this case we totally support
this but we'd go a lot further
the school street 20 mile an hour zone
the area around it should be a low
traffic neighborhood
and framingham road which runs parallel
to brooklyn's road
doesn't need to be a through road
it needs to be filtered it's a
residential street
and in the safe streets trafford
consultation
one respondent had this to say they said
framingham road is used as a rat run
by vehicles trying to avoid cues on
brooklyn's road
closing it to through traffic would
prevent this and open it up for people
to
cycle on it as an alternative to the
canal path especially at night when the
canal is unlit
this blind bend is a serious accident
waiting to happen
the parked cars on the eastern side mean
that southbound cars have to drive on
the wrong side of the road
this is often done at speed and with no
consideration
to the traffic heading north please
close this rat run
i suggest we follow the advice of both
this petition and
this this person on the safe streets
stratfor safe streets trafford we're
getting the information
from residents let's use it thank you
councillor welton
please can the deputy leader of the
council summarize for the council
and our guest what will happen with this
petition
yes thank you um mayor and thank you
mrs delatorre for bringing this petition
and really appreciate you bringing this
and for articulating your concerns so
clearly
and my understanding is that gmp
don't support the stop sign and i think
you
you articulated that yourself there and
in light of that and the fact that the
department for transport regulations
also don't support
um the stop sign um in that it wouldn't
be compliant
and then this is something that we're
not able to
implement however as councillor has said
and there are a number of measures that
we do want to um
implement including making the sign that
is there
more prominent and we do want to keep
that dialogue open with you
around your suggestions and we will make
sure that we do that so that we can
um get some solutions for you but thank
you very much for bringing that tonight
thank you councillor hines thank you mr
lator
item six is the places for everyone
publication draft
2021 plan which was approved by the
executive on monday
and council is now asked to agree that
the plan be submitted to the secretary
of state for examination
following the period for representations
the executive member for housing and
regeneration council the right
is to introduce the report and move the
recommendations
councillor wright please thank you chair
and my apologies to anyone who is
executive on monday night if i'm
repeating myself um
i'm delighted to bring this report to
council which is a strategic plan
to deal with the housing crisis across
greater manchester
and provide guaranteed land for
employment helping the local economy to
grow following the
kovid 19 pandemic as i'm sure members
are aware
the background to this plan is that in
trafford we see we simply do not have
the brownfield land supply
available to build the homes that we
need both the housing land availability
assessment and the call for sites have
confirmed that
we have and will continue to take a
brownfield first approach
but this is simply not enough we have a
housing crisis in trafford and across
greater manchester
the average home costs over eight times
the average salary
there are thousands of people waiting
for social housing and we cannot and
will not turn a blind eye to this
this plan will see some land release
from the greenbelt in order to meet our
housing targets
and deal with the housing crisis however
this plan
in comparison to previous iterations
sees a significant reduction in
greenbelt loss
in the original gmsf plan from 2016 not
just did we
have significantly more loss at
carrington and simply wedge
but we also had loss at flixton as
members will be aware
flixton has been removed as part of the
negotiations with greater manchester
and there have been significant
reductions across both camp carrington
and simply 72 hectares save
saved in carrington and 14 hectares
saved in timperley in the current places
for everyone plan
this equates to a reduction of circa 40
percent
in greenbelt loss over the last five
years
as members will be aware without a
collaborative approach
with the other eight gm authorities now
excluding stockport of course
we will be required to find land for a
further 5 000 homes
this would inevitably lead to even
further greenbelt loss
as we simply do not have the land within
the urban area
that could meet this need whilst most of
the headlines surrounding gmsf are now
places for everyone have been dominated
by housing
and setting a new greenbelt boundary
there are other very positive parts of
the plan which are worth noting
firstly as the war councillor who
represents carrington
and the nearby communities of partington
and southwest
this plan provides the framework to
further support and
enhance the regeneration of partington
and carrington itself
partington is the most isolated part of
trafford and one of the most deprived
one of the key issues faced in
partington is a lack of access to good
jobs
across trafford and the wider gm
conurbation
the transport links are simply not good
enough the the public transport
provision is not fit for purpose as per
the report the pla this plan works
alongside the gm transport plan 2040
which proposes to enhance sustainable
modes of travel
and improve upon the existing transport
network whilst making travel more
sustainable through public transport and
walking and cycling routes
the road network that connects
partington to the rest of greater
manchester
is simply not good enough manchester
road is simply not up to the task
to enable the regeneration of partington
to alleviate the
the issues faced by villages in
carrington a new road is required
the options for that new road will
become later this year come clearer
later this year
however let's be clear we cannot have
sustainable and better public transport
without a road which is fit for purpose
we cannot alleviate the issues faced by
people who live on manchester road
without taking heavy traffic off this
road
secondly and this list is not exhaustive
places for everyone supports the gm
vision to be carbon neutral by 2028
and enhances the protection of green
open spaces like in southwest
there are also more detailed policies on
mitigating the impacts of climate change
members who vote against this plan
tonight are voting against a plan
which is half the greenbelt taking
simply wedge compared to the tourist
plan in 2016
are voting against saving the proposed
release of greenbelt in flixton
again a proposal made by the tories and
are voting against
significant reductions in the greenbelt
release in carrington
let me make it very clear this is the
only genuine plant on the table that
meets our housing
need our housing targets and begins to
tackle the
housing crisis without this plan we open
trafford up to unplanned greenbelt
development
which won't be in the hands of people
locally but will be decided upon by the
planning inspector
given the importance of this vote i
formally request a recorded vote on this
item when we come to it
thank you chair thank you councillor
right
um is that seconded please
it is seconded thank you um
and i am happy to second the places for
everyone proposal
this evening um there is a national
and a local housing crisis and in the
very near future
there won't be enough places for
everyone to live
even without a government policy passed
on to local authorities
we can't ignore that and we have to act
now and the places for everyone proposal
is the responsible way
to plan for our future
to build the new homes that are needed
and to provide
vital employment opportunities and
infrastructure
i'm hoping that cross party members will
be supportive of the plans
but note that there was some opposition
expressed in the executive meeting on
monday
i'd like to reflect that it isn't very
long ago that the gmsf
was comprehensively advocated by the
previous administration
conservative councillors when in
administration
spoke passionately about the need for
the spatial framework
and about being responsible in ensuring
sufficient housing for the next
generation and the plans for trafford
drawn up by the previous administration
as councillor wright has said
included the building of 750 homes on
flexton fields
the labour administration immediately
removed the fields from those proposals
because this wasn't a responsible way to
do it
and have since protected the land for
use by the community
we've also worked sensitively
appropriately and collaboratively
to reduce to achieve a reduction in
building on green belt land
by almost half that which was put
forward by the former
conservative administration
and we may hear some discussion tonight
from liberal democrat colleagues
that brownfield land should be developed
first
and yes whilst the places for everyone
plant
has adopted an approach to use as much
brownfield land as possible
it is the case that brownfield only land
will not be sufficient to achieve the
numbers of homes required
it would not be feasible nor a sound
approach
to wait for brownfield land to become
available
and as such in order to ensure the next
generation
has somewhere to live and opportunities
to work
we need to release release some land
from the green belt
i haven't sedate heard an opposition
argument
that proposes a responsible way to
tackle the housing shortage
um and urge all members to get behind
this plan thank you mayor thank you
council hines
um as indicated earlier we have a number
of people listed who are going to speak
to this item
so we're going to go to those speakers
first councillor evans
thank you mr mayor the long running
conversation around places for everyone
formerly known as the gmsf is a rehash
of an outdated scheme
the mayor andy burnham name change is a
soft sell of the greater manchester
spatial framework
into a places for everyone and is
clearly a recognition that the old name
and old plan didn't cut the mustard
this new name attempts to hoodwink
residents into believing
it's a different plan and that it's not
all about
taking the easy option of building all
over our greenbelt
only on monday at the executive meeting
we had councillor freeman informing us
that
businesses will be failing due to covid
and the world had changed
those changes are amongst many that make
the repeated decision to continue with
an outdated plan
and not focus on the existing and new
brownfield sites
that councillor freeman recognizes it's
just unacceptable
all this while trafford council have
called a climate emergency last year
in our usual council chamber and yet in
the next breath
plan to concrete our green belt
dare i say the new plan is a wolf in
sheep's clothing
detrimental to the residents of trafford
and must be voted against
as we saw happen in stockport there are
alternative approaches stockport for
example has chosen
a new route trafford has been lazy and
relied upon andy burnham who barely
visits our borough
to put together our plan for us
i ask you where are the school places
for the developments we have going on
already
we have none let alone the additional
places that this new plan will demand
children cannot be crammed into schools
as this labour administration
is insisting upon we have already had
planning applications suggesting that
children from trafford
attend schools in warrington and salford
all gm authorities must adopt a fresh
plan that ensures greenbelt land
continues to be protected
and is not released while any brownfield
sites are available
and stop laying the blame at the
government for their own dereliction of
duty
brownfield sites are available for
development and we will no doubt see
more
that is why we must get on with our own
local plan
immediately just because it's easy to
build on the green spaces and cheaper is
no justification
for building on our green belt and the
housing minister robert generic not
last week states you can only build on
the green belt with clear
justification and then there clearly
isn't
warm words from labor and others on
housing need must be balanced with
residents that already live
in trafford they deserve to live in an
area where the council maximizes
the brownfield sites and has a plan with
green spaces protected
for their families we need a local plan
from local people that's smart and fluid
and builds homes on brownfield sites
whilst ensuring we have the
infrastructure to support it
things have changed to be clear we have
a labour mayor
we have a labor council and here we have
a labour plan
thank you mr mayor thank you councillor
evans
and councillor new grosh
can i say to everybody can we can we
listen listen to the speakers please
i really don't i don't like people
interrupting um
people are quite welcome to speak and
i don't feel it's right that there's
background noises occurring when they
are speaking councillor new gross
councillors mr mayor not all decisions
we take here are equal
this is arguably the furthest reaching
and most controversial
we may ever vote on you are all aware of
my personal
and the liberal democrats group
long-standing opposition
to this deeply flawed and unsound plan
let me explain why the whole of gms f2
or places for everyone is based on
flawed growth growth predictions
made way back in 2014 a time before
brexit
and it's predicted 5 shrinkage to the
economy by 2030
a time that could not conceive of a
pandemic claiming tens
of thousands of lives it is abundantly
clear the data
underpinning the whole plan is wrong and
growing more so as a year's pass
and why the hurry the 2021 census data
is available in a few months
solid data that could underpin a better
plan
our local plan another critical failing
is a complete lack of requirement to use
any of our brownfield availability
despite councillor rights protestations
this is a clearly a greenbelt first plan
in fact he has admitted on monday that
it's green belt from day one
no requirement for developers to touch
the land banks they sit on
no incentive at all this plan gives free
reign
carte blanche to build on greenbelt the
second its past
how perverse that we find labour
executive putting developers profit
margins
before their own residence i must at
this point address
housing need it as it is fundamental yes
councillors
we need housing affordable social low
carbon housing this plan identifies
enough brownfield
to provide over sixteen thousand four
hundred
dwellings roughly fourteen years supply
brownfields such as balka court in my
ward
what this plan completely lacks is a
requirement for
to use it this plan also
fails any test of fairness the three
most densely populated wards of trafford
are clifford timperley and templey
village
the highest density housing in timperley
are the residents of broomewood
these plans build literally across the
road from them
robbing them of the only significant
open space for miles around
you are destroying the green belt next
to the residents that can least afford
to
its loss one of the many insanities of
this plan is that it allocates greenbelt
for new office space even before covid
we were converting offices into
apartments
but since the pandemic forced a
fundamental shift in working practices
it makes this allocation even more
absurd
this plan makes no acknowledgment of or
consideration to the changes that
covert has brought finally as time is
regretfully short
i must address the ecological damage you
will unleash
should you vote for this timply wedge is
the main rainfall
catchment areas for the rivers farewell
and timply brook
both of these have flooded twice in the
two years i have been a councillor
one in a hundred year events i'm told
flooding
many of my residents homes this plan
will ensure
more frequent and devastating floods
perhaps the greatest crime i've left to
last
carrington moss is a peat moss of up to
three
meters in depth the destruction of this
critical carbon sink
will release mega tons of carbon
making a total mockery of both
trafford's carbon budget
and our climate emergency both of which
you voted through recently
voting for this plan would be hypocrisy
of the highest order
there is no docking responsibility for
this should you vote for it
just following orders won't wash any
more than it has in the past
consider your conscience counsellors
demand better
reject this unsound plan vote against
thank you thank you councillor new grosh
councillor coggins you have
five minutes
thank you mayor and um i wanted to start
by thanking all the officers and indeed
councillors who've worked on this it's
been a massive and extremely difficult
job over a very long time
and i think we need to acknowledge that
difficulty and acknowledge the
improvements that the current
administration have made
compared to previous drafts of this and
it was always going to be fiendishly
difficult
and i think there are no easy answers
here
we have a housing crisis and so we need
more homes but we have a climate and
ecological emergency and so we need to
protect
our green spaces now we in the green
party agree
that um working together across nine or
ten boroughs was the right approach
however we believe that the principles
used to tackle it have been flawed
the underlying principle of this project
should have been about building the
homes and infrastructure we need
whilst protecting our climate and nature
we know that we cannot have endless
growth on a finite planet
and this plan sadly gives too much
priority to economic growth
at the expense of our own well-being we
need some climate realism here
now typically wedge and carrington moss
will have fewer homes built on them
than similarly sized pla areas here in
the civic quarter
if we had taken a greener approach we
will be looking at a different type of
plan today
a plan for higher densities with lower
traffic
for an abundance of housing but on
smaller footprints
we would have seen a much bigger move
away from car dependence
and towards the sort of 20 20-minute
neighborhoods that we see in the
netherlands and other world cities
areas with lots of green space
affordable housing high densities and
where it's safe and pleasant to walk
cycle and for children to play outdoors
of particular concern of course are the
wetlands at carrington moss
wetlands we know are unique because what
happens when a plant dies in the
wetlands
unlike a wood or anywhere else is that
the carbon it has absorbed
is of course buried under water for
millions
of years and we know that um technology
firms are trying so hard to develop this
sort of technology
and we could be having it happening here
in trafford for free
this is really challenging and i know
and i acknowledge the difficulty the
administration faces with this
carrington moss is not a living bog at
the moment but we know
experts agree it has the potential to be
restored
it's also in private hands i know it's
not easy
we can't force them to change but we
have to remember
how impossibly difficult the
alternatives are
council really needs to be doing
everything it can to protect this vital
resource
we need to be working with landowners
and lobbying government to do everything
we can to restore vital
wetlands and protect them from
developers not enabling any further
destruction
these plans are also calling very
worryingly for a doubling of airport use
over the next 20 years
now the airports say they want to do
this without having any negative impacts
on the climate but we all know that that
is frankly science fiction and the
technology to do that
does not exist 70 of flights are taken
only by 15
of the population so increasing airport
use is about really a small number of
people
creating a large amount of pollution at
the expense of the most vulnerable
people
on our planet we must keep remembering
that climate justice
is social justice and i know that our
friends in the labour party have a deep
commitment to social justice
but i do sometimes feel that labour has
a blind spot around climate justice
we're not really talking about places
for everyone when our actions
risk destroying the homes of others
through fires floods and droughts
now there are realistic and serious
alternatives available
i've described the difference in
densities the different approaches to
transport that we could be taking
but they require thinking outside the
box
and henry ford supposedly said if he had
asked people what they wanted
they would have said faster horses
people just couldn't imagine the scale
of the changes that were coming to them
at that point in time
well we are now on the cusp of an
altogether different
change a change of the kind we have
never
seen before an irreversible change
we should have a plan here to solve the
housing crisis
while tackling the climate crisis we
should have an economy that works for
people and planet
not the other way around but this plan
is offering us faster horses and the
green group will be voting against it
tonight
thank you thank you councillor coggins
councillor freeman
you have two minutes councillor freeman
please
thank you thank you mayor
i speak in favor of places for everyone
and go into consultation which is
essentially about the soundness of the
plan
this plan is about ensuring housing and
infrastructure
to support that to enable people that
need housing
including traffic residents can have
access to it now i i look around this
room and i know the vast majority of us
in here
already have access to a safe and secure
home and indeed some of us
have access to more than one home i also
look around this room and i see members
opposite
who object to six thousand units being
built on green space but we're
previously in favor
of eleven thousand units being built on
green space
it seems to me that they left their
principles behind
when they went into opposition i simply
say to the detractors of this plan
what is it that prevents you from
wanting for others
what you have already got
what is it that you find so objectional
to objectionable to this plan
and you know i've really really tried to
fathom that out
and have failed so i simply say to those
who have objections to this plan and
seek to object to its soundness
just please shut up because ultimately
you are
failing the very communities you purport
to serve
and by the way councillor evans
stockport's example
is to write asking other councils to
meet their housing needs
but not offering to take any of our
needs from us
and councillor newgrosh our housing need
is set nationally
and is not something in our gift and
councillor goggins i heard what you said
but i'm afraid we cannot achieve utopia
thank you mayor
thank you councillor freeman councillor
miss blackburn
you have two minutes thank you
thank you mr mayor um due to time
restrictions i'm limiting to what i have
to say
just to two areas so i will be very
brief
with regard to the proposals for
temporary wedge area
i'm extremely concerned as to how in
actuality
vehicles accessing warehousing
businesses
will be able to travel along the fairly
narrow roads
of park road stockport road and thorley
lane
through timperley village and wait a
minute
village that's the word is there a clue
there
will properties have to be compulsorily
purchased and demolished
in order to provide suitable
thoroughfares for laden
goods vehicles i don't think it's the
right place
for warehousing facilities secondly
wilver and i mentioned this to exec on
monday
will there be a reappraisal of the
amount of office floor space
identified in the timply wedge proposal
following the experiences of covid many
employees will choose to work from home
in the future
and many employers will want to reduce
the office space
used by their organizations and it's
vital
that these numbers are evaluated
that's all i have to say thank you
people do need homes
but offices and warehousing needs to be
put
in an appropriate space and not on
green land thank you
thank you councillor ms blackburn
councillor brophy you have two minutes
thank you
thank you mr mayor so firstly this is
just not a sound plan
but i would say one thing in support of
the labor group here the
greater manchester spatial framework
places for everyone plan that the
tory group have said is more or less the
same i've stood on a platform with
predecessors here the tories have
passionately
been in favor of this plan before as a
bit of a turnaround
on behalf of the conservative group here
so the group
it fails this plan there's been
inadequate community engagement
that has been outlined by other
colleagues there are two peat mosses in
trafford the one at carrington
is is is viable as has been stated
and it's a crime against the environment
to be developing on a peak moss
especially and on the green belt
entirely
so regarding the timberly wedge it's as
councillor hugh gross has outlined
it's one of the few green spaces in the
timply area
and it's also providing a vital resource
of people it also
helps with blood protection and with the
climate change emergency that i do agree
with councillor goggins on this that
we're not looking at utopia when we're
tackling climate change we're
we're tackling the worst crisis that
humanity has ever faced
and looking at building on greenbelt is
people are going to look back and think
why on earth did we do that it's a crazy
crazy plan
so it's also not tackling the housing
crisis and
it's not doing that of course we want to
have housing for people of course we
want to tackle
the homeless problem but the type of
houses that will be built on simply
wedge
will not be affordable by the younger
generation they won't be affordable by
people who already live in the area it
doesn't solve the crisis prices at all
also the problems with building on the
green belt is the infrastructure just
isn't there
there are no schools in the south ultron
areas or has already been outlined
and there's no health facilities there
enough to support people
there's a lack of public transport
infrastructure there aren't any
public transport any trains or buses
that will be
able to use people it's just encouraging
people back into the cars which we don't
want
so getting back to the environment this
is clearly not a sustainable plan the
amount of carbon emissions
that from building on the green belt
particularly peat moss are just
astronomical megatons will be released
there are brownfield sites in trafford
as have been outlined using coffee
council you need to in summary it's not
a pla
a sound plan and i would urge trafford
councillors to vote against thank you mr
mayor
thank you councillor brophy councillor
morgan
thank you mr mayor there's an audible um
aim in this plan
of building more homes but let's be
clear mr mayor this plan is not fit for
purpose
firstly there's the thousands of new um
office units being proposed despite the
most rapid change to working
from home um in generations nothing in
this plan takes care of the post-covered
world which will transform
the way and more importantly where we
work indeed labour's deputy leaders only
today announced that they want the right
to work to be an automatic
default right there's nothing in this
plan to facilitate the brownfield first
approach that councillor wright has
claimed
indeed council officers today have
confirmed and i quote
it is not a sound approach to restrict
green failed development until
brownfield
land is developed so is councillor right
really asking us to just
trust developers not to choose
greenfield um
first nothing in this plan guarantees
new school places for the thousands of
children be moving into my ward before
the houses are built
nothing guaranteed for transport links
not even confirmed funding for the
support the carrington relief road or
the tympani spine
mr mayor it's clear these plans need
rejecting in favor of an actual
brownfield first approach i hope this
chamber joins us tonight in rejecting
these
thank you councillor morgan councillor
minis
hello okay it's working um thank you mr
mayor so
in my understanding this is gmsf but you
know slightly rebranded
so there's two to me there's two aspects
that i'm gonna i'm gonna look at this in
terms of planning so to me
um in terms of planning for the simply
wedge there isn't the road
infrastructure for it
we haven't got as um council brophy said
we haven't got we're
not going to have the public transport
so it's going to push people into cars
roads like park road and other similar
ones
and they're too congested to take the
additional traffic
the housing there is not going to be
affordable so in terms of waiting
you just don't have it there and you're
going to put about half a million pound
and over homes
not affordable the air the area
is also a conservation area there as
there are many
rare species of birds and
that nest there along with the grated
crested mutes and other species
this is their home and any relocation
plan for them
they don't get emails they don't read
emails um would be disturbing their
habitat and would actually contribute
to their decline in their extinction the
flooding risks then turn into flooding
certainty under the climate emergency
that we're in
because tympani has flooded lots of
times in the past couple of years
with carrington moss we're digging up
the huge amounts of carbon in the
peatland
area is irresponsible and how on earth
this is
even an idea i find very strange
we make decisions here all of us make
decisions here for future generations
it's not just for the next 10 years next
20 years it's for
way way into the future and we have to
consider
the impact of our decisions and we need
to take them seriously
we can't be just going well you know we
need to build some houses
there's a nice piece of bit of land we
can just build it on there and not think
about the consequences
we need to think thank you
thank you councillor minis councillor
patel
thank you like its predecessor places
for everyone has become a political
football to the extent we're in the
perverse place of receiving news of
reduced housing building figures
as a positive outcome the only voice not
heard in this debate is the voice of
those in housing need
brownfield first is the policy now and
it has been for many years
yet we are still unable to meet our
housing targets
the irony here is that all opposition
parties will be prepared to see every
scrap of land in old trafford for
example
developed with no thoughts spared for
the impacts on that community
in response to the quip from councillor
newgosh about the labour administration
being in
in with developers the lib dems had a
very recent chance
to to live their housing values and
they've just flogged their site
to the highest bidder for luxury
development
place places for everyone is about so
much more than the greenbelt
that we are seriously considering a
once-in-a-generation strategic plan
that looks at our infrastructure jobs
transport network
environmental assets at a scale that is
geographically meaningful
should be embraced i am ashamed that it
has been kicked down the road for so
many years
please let's just get on with it thank
you councillor patel
councillor holden
thank you
i hope that uh you'll forgive me if my
voice falters a little tonight
i'm actually going through a deep
personal crisis
i'm agreeing with the greens and the
liberal democrats
and for an old conservative you've no
idea how painful that feels
the other is the shock the true and
heartfelt
shock to discover that for the last 17
years
i haven't been representing sail west
it's entirely been done
by councillor wright and i'm sure that
in summing up you'll be able to
point out that there are three others
from this side of the house
who have been proudly and joyfully
representing the residents of sail west
for our entire political career
i must admire the ingenuity of this plan
to actually reduce the amount of
carrington moss which will be
taken up on paper whilst protecting an
abandoned golf course in flixton
is truly politically wonderful
however if you look at the rather
beautifully prepared
diagrams you'll notice that western way
and burnham boulevard the two major
roads ripping across the mosque
have been carefully positioned so that
the areas on either side of them
are small limited by roads
and hence vulnerable to a very powerful
developer
who wants to build everywhere on that
area
there is no doubt that we could do some
more housing
i'm a little worried that we went
through the pain of arguing about a
climate
crisis only to find it doesn't exist
because we can rip up and meet a peak
bog
we can build those houses but if you
build the roads
the developers will turn up and build
again because they don't want to build
on brownfield that's the holder no
developer doesn't hold anything
field first thank you thank you
councillor holden
i'm going to ask councillor wright to
reply
thank you thank you chair um i'm not
quite sure where to start with some of
these responses
um this evening but just to start with
councillor evans um
i'm not sure he's been hugging council
evans because you created the original
plan
um and that concrete is someone's home
by the way um i'm not i'm not going to
go near your past
obsession with school places because
that's been addressed by councillor
carter one of my colleagues on
on many occasions and your comments
regarding the local plan
you were part of the cross party
consultative group on the local plans
you should know that that's already
underway
um and to mention robert genwick well
let's face it he's got form for
justifying planning applications above
the planning inspector
has he nots
counselor new goshen councillor morgan
just to disc i mean you both
sort of meant you both almost mentioned
land banking as you're both aware land
banking is a government policy and
there's nothing we can do about it
um particularly council morgan if you've
got an issue with land banking
and and the influence of developers
maybe you should lobby your own
government to change that
um council negoti mentioned the pandemic
has changed everything the pan-tan
pandemic hasn't shrunken the
homelessness crisis councilor newgross
in fact it's worsened it you may have
noticed why the rush you said councillor
negros
because we have a housing crisis that's
why there's a rush
councillor coggins higher densities
so it seems that the green party are
happy to shove everyone over there
and high dens heights in high density
development
as long as we get to keep our green
spaces not
in my backyard
councillor brophy no affordable housing
45 percent as a minimum in temporary
wedge
15 as a minimum in carrington and
affordable housing as you well know is
not the only solution to this housing
crisis
we are the only party in this room who
are taking the housing crisis seriously
we have a housing target which we must
meet if we do not follow this plan
more greenbelt will be released for
development it will be unfettered
development across the borough
and will be in serious trouble and far
more of our value green spaces will be
lost
i asked the council to approve the plan
thank you chair thank you councillor
wright so we're going to go to the vote
and
we've council rights asked for a
recorded vote
can all those in favor of the plan
please raise your hand and
we will count you and write your names
down
you
okay hands down those against
okay hands down any abstentions
no abstentions okay i think that's been
can it give the numbers
can we have the numbers please ian
thank you i think that's been carried
thank you everybody
item number seven is a report of the
lead of the council regarding the
greater manchester clean air final plan
and i invite the deputy leader
councillor hinds to introduce
and move the item
is going to move it apologies counselor
it's going to move
this item
right thank you yeah the report before
us this evening is one of the most
important reports
in relation to the public health agenda
we have seen in a long time
the report is comprehensive and fully
details how this scheme
has been developed over the last few
years modelling has shown the extent
of the health-related problems that this
work
could help save the equipment of some
1200 lives around greater manchester
each year
due to the effects of pollution as well
as many other respiratory diseases
the health benefits of cleaner air
that this will bring are enormous and
they will be welcomed across
gm and were supported fully by residents
during the consultation in developing
the kc
scheme each category of vehicle class
has to be justified
and to show that by including it it will
help contribute
to the earliest possible date of
compliance if we could not demonstrate
this
it could be subject to legal challenge
it is a scheme
we consulted on and it was agreed being
agreed across gm
once approved it is legally binding and
we cannot
has been shared by some simply move to a
new type of scheme
such as a casd to suggest this is utter
nonsense
we have been given clear ministerial
direction on this for cassie scheme
and the modeling has shown gm will be
compliant as directed
with trafford one of the first to reach
compliance
now retrofit technology for light
vehicles is new to the market however
any approved retrofit solutions are now
supported by the plan
to ensure the most flexible solutions
possible can be considered
it is an emerging technology and whilst
this is an option for around 10
of vehicles it is expected this figure
will increase
as mortal fits are developed over the
queen months
however it will not be suitable for all
vehicles including older ones
any vehicle having a retrofit must of
course
have a viable life
lifetime span give me a set i've just
lost my place now with this
it's not yes uh however
it that will say it not too far away
including older ones any vehicle having
a vet
i retrofit must of course have a
suitable life scan and therefore
grants are available as an alternative
to retrofit
part of the work in granting an
extension to the exemption for lgvs
must help sure ensure the time for a
viable secondhand market to develop
which has been discussed extensively
over the last couple of years
i would add of course that when trading
in any vehicle
you would only of course be given its
actual value to suggest as some have
suggested
that we only consider new vehicles for
every one of these
is absolute nonsense when you trade in
your car like i traded in mine last year
i did not get the full value as it was
when it was new i got what it's actually
worth and i think that that is actually
direction
that this is going now the extension as
i've just said for lgvs was to help
develop
that market with second-hand compliance
vehicles
and that is the way that a lot of this
will be going we cannot please everybody
on that but it is really the direction
we need to go to ensure we get
compliance and this is about
health i'd also like to draw members
attention
particularly to sections six and seven
which give a clear understanding
of the consultation its outcomes and
information regarding
to each vehicle class i would add
that work will continue in seeking
hardship funds
as moved to implementation this is a
very important aspect of the work
and remember opposite have any concerns
on this i would urge you to lobby your
government to give us those funds to do
it
rather than just simply saying here to
scrap the scheme in finishing
i would remind members that this scheme
is a result of action being taken as
government
for failing to improve air quality
and the levels of pollution that go with
that i hope that members
would agree this is their important
strategy i would ask that you do support
it
thank you councillor i'd said councillor
hines you're going to second the motion
yes thank you ma um and could i put um
request permission to speak from a
seated position actually i was having
trouble seeing when i was stood up
before if that's okay
thank you thank you um
so i'm really happy to second the
proposals for the greater manchester
clean air plan and there was some
opposition expressed in monday night's
executive meeting
from the leader of the conservative
group and seemingly that the proposals
are
unfair to small businesses and
labour in greater manchester through
council of
western as gm lead have lobbied the
government on behalf of businesses
for a hardship fund and whilst the
conservative
government are apparently not convinced
by this
the authorities in greater manchester
will carefully monitor
this situation however as councillor ads
head has said
it is important to note that many
businesses will be able to part
exchange their vehicles most businesses
including small operators do regularly
upgrade their vehicles
in any event and time has been given to
businesses
with non-compliant vehicles to put plans
in place
and make the appropriate changes and
many businesses
have rightly already begun to do that
but actually what the last 18 months
have taught us
is that health and wealth lives
and livelihoods are not mutually
exclusive
driving around all day in a vehicle that
emits
harmful levels of nitrogen dioxide
whilst in streams of traffic also
emitting
harmful pollutants is incredibly
dangerous to health
it can live limits at the number of
healthy years a person has
and detrimentally impacting their lives
including their long-term capacity to
work
and prolonged exposure to dangerous
particulates in the air
has been shown to shorten life
expectancy
the statistics quoted in the report are
damning
with young children older people and
those living in
areas of detriment deprivation
being the most vulnerable developing
council
wrapping up um so we might hear from our
green party colleagues that the green
air plan
doesn't go far enough and actually we
would have wanted to see the government
go further and but it is
vital that we start somewhere and this
plan is a culmination of a huge amount
of work
we can't afford not to act all modeling
shows that this plan will achieve
compliance with the legal limits for
nitrogen dioxide within greater
manchester
in the shortest possible time and i urge
all members to get behind it thank you
thank you councillor hines councillor
evans you'd like to speak to this item
thank you mr mayor the conservative
group over many months have raised
concerns
with tfgm about this clean air plan for
greater manchester
uh being proposed by the gmail andy
burnham and before us tonight
we are fully supportive of clean air in
our borough and across the region
which i'm delighted to report according
to all tfgm documentation
2019 and 2020 we have come nowhere
near to hitting our air quality
targets which makes the proposal
presented before us tonight
hardly necessary this 493
square mile folly is unquestionably the
largest
and most punishing tax on small business
that greater manchester and more
importantly
trafford has ever seen a tax that is
going ahead
even though we have had confirmation
from andrew weston
in our own chamber that we have not
breached any targets
the projections that we are assaulted
with from tfgm
a conjecture and are questioned by labor
and consent
conservative mps across gm
only as an executive last week i
highlighted our concerns
regarding the retrofit scheme labor
cannot seem to understand
this is a case of the emperor's new
clothes our concerns have been proven
by tfgm um at the 11th hour tftm have
analyzed data from the society of motor
manufacturers and traders
you won't know this countless then only
after weeks of questioning
openly admit that only 10 percent of the
non-compliant lgbs in gm
are retrofittable this fact clearly
absent
from all our briefings and the papers
before us tonight
this means that ninety percent of light
vans
are not retrofittable an overwhelming
majority of owners will need to make use
of the vehicle renewable scheme
council ad says have clearly admitted he
does not understand supply and demand
these part x values will be zero
these owners will only qualify for no
more than four and a half thousand pound
grant
towards a van cost of thirty thousand
pounds your car valet will need to find
25 000 pounds
the line spouted out by council asset is
that the government must pay
more to the hardship fund i would argue
that paying for a ludicrously large
400 493 square mile
unnecessary unnecessary congestion tax
is going to be a tough sell
for any sensible taxpayer to swallow as
we come out of this pandemic and work
towards recovery
we must support our businesses not
punish them on this basis that the final
plan is not transparent
the conservative group cannot support
this plan
it is time for this council to be honest
with businesses and residents in
trafford
they are putting in cameras that are
going to punish them and that
consultation on this matter was not well
advertised three percent response rate
and small business owners have been
misled that the retrofitting of vehicles
will help
the majority of them this simply is not
the case
we all support clean air but cannot
support this plan
ask the mayor to produce a realistic
plan there are many
other options he knows this he just
wants the cash we won't be supporting we
will be abstaining on this plan we
support clean air but this plan
is folly
thank you councillor evans councillor
brophy please
thank you mr mayor speaking on behalf of
the broad democrat group we do welcome
this plan
but it does not go far enough i
understand there'll be 90 million
for hardware and extra staffing costs
but the problem with the plan as it is
is it doesn't make the air clean it only
covers
nitrogen dioxide this is just one
pollutant
it doesn't cover the dangerous
particulates that are known
to cause life-shortening illness so
we support the plan but it's not radical
enough the liberal democrats would like
to see more pollution tackled
and we'd like to see our air properly
clean thank you
thank you councillor brophy councillor
coggins please
thank you mayor um clean air is is a
basic right
something we shouldn't have to fight for
and we support this plan we welcome it
and we will be voting for it
um as cancer brophy has said and
councillor heinz
suspected i would say this plan is
nowhere near ambitious enough
and as greens we want to go so much
further this plan
aims to get us to legal levels of one
pollutant
and it will take us absolutely nowhere
near the world health organization's
recommendations for
maximum levels of pollution and as
greens we'd like to see a new clean air
act with strict laws and a new watchdog
with the powers to enforce those laws to
guarantee that we all have
air that we can breathe that won't make
us ill the second problem that we have
heard from others
is its plan needed a decent hardship
fund from government
to support our small businesses taxi
drivers and sole traders
you've heard those arguments before we
have to remember though as well
that the very drivers who are impacted
by this are some of the people whose
health will be most
impacted too and we also need to
remember the economy
the economic arguments for clean air and
research from the cbi have said
that the economy would increase by 1.6
billion pounds a year if we met the
who's standards on clean air
so it really is time i think that
trafford conservatives stopped fighting
public health measures and asked their
own government to step up
to support our health and to support our
economy
now i know the administration will tell
us that they wanted to go further but of
course they don't have the funds from
government
and but if clean repair if clean air was
a real priority there are many things
that are within their powers that you
could be doing right now
we could be going so much faster on
supporting safe and pleasant
walking and cycling we could bring
bringing in 20 mile per hour zones
all around the places where we live
making a huge impact on the places we
live
and even simple measures like asking for
signs for drivers not to idle at
level crossings have been on the back
boiler for years
other places like nottingham london and
walton forest have led the way on this
they've brought in workplace
parking levees they've brought in
congestion charges
and active transport schemes so the
dirty air that we're breathing here
it's not inevitable this is a result of
political choice
so i want to invite you all to vote
today for this plan but pledge to
yourself
and to your residents that this is just
a first step that this is not
enough getting clean air it's not rocket
science
it doesn't require huge amounts of
research or unachievable levels of
funding
there are many steps we could do today
that were within the budget and the
powers of this council to make change
this is about making it a priority to
ensure that every resident who you serve
has air to breathe that will not make
the mill
thank you thank you councillor coggins
councillor morgan
mike can for a recorded vote on this
scene is again a very important vote
i really wish i could support this mr
mayor because i do think we have an
issue with air quality
it's why so many other cities are coming
up with innovative plans to tackle it
but this plan isn't just fit and isn't
good enough
there's a real issue in the city centre
and certain motorway junctions which are
detailed in the documentation we've all
been sent
so why isn't the gmca tackling the
issues
in both of these rather than slamming a
van when it's just driving on some of
our rural roads
even the modeling which is in the
appendix to the this report
shows it won't tackle all of the issues
in the city centre
and why is that because the approach is
wrong
half the vehicles which exceed the limit
won't be charged
and those are the ones likely to be sat
idling
so what we'll have we'll have a van in
the moorlands
being charged as it crosses into saddle
worth being hit but an old
clapped out banger sat in traffic
billowing out black fumes in the
northern quarter
won't be affected plus these charges
won't just hurt some businesses will
kill some businesses
at probably our weakest economic
position since 1945
all whilst not tackling the problems in
our worst spots
therefore i reluctantly cannot support
these proposals
thank you thank you councillor morgan
and councillor ad said you have the
right to reply
thank you
we are on the the time button here
uh council of freedom and i'm going to
allow two people and if you insist i'm
going to allow two people
councillor freeman and anybody else
council back burn one from each side
okay
i'll be a minute i'm afraid councillor i
support the clean airplane and the
recommendations of the paper in doing so
i'd like to address whether or not in
terms of providing for clean air the
plan goes far enough
what i would say is i think all of us
here would really like like
in the interest of maximizing the
prospect of clean and red to go further
and address other types of pollutants
that said it's important to remember at
this stage gm is only being funded to
reduce roadside
nitrogen dioxide emissions that funding
effectively ties the hands
and the plan will do what it says i'm
also aware some in the rumor of the view
that the exemptions insert into the plan
will delay compliance for some vehicles
but
the delay in compliance with some
vehicles by 12 months is that odds with
what we're legally required to do
i think they need to understand we're
now a different starting point
air quality has changed during the pant
due to the pandemic
and also the implementation of the plan
has been pushed back they
pushed back the exemptions in the plan
now offer businesses
the packages that have been negotiated
the opportunity to upgrade non-compliant
vehicles
which is important because modeling and
feedback from consultation demonstrates
that without exemptions businesses would
stay put stay
and pay the new charges the most
misleading statement with councillor
freeman tonight
really needed councillor evans when he
said calls it a tax
it is not a tax and he knows it thank
you mr mayor thank you councillor
freeman councillor miss blackburn you
have one minute
thank you the greater manchester clean
air plan
will be a bit of a nonsense as the whole
area is intersected with motorways which
will not be affected by it
as they are controlled by highways
england as a nasa sufferer
i need better quality air but feel
that these creeping charges will
adversely affect
our small businesses i asked at the
exact meeting on monday
where the monies would go and what would
be spent on but i couldn't hear the
answer
my own vehicle is 10 years old and i've
never been in a position
to buy a new vehicle is this the thin
end of the wedge and will cars be next
thank you mr mayor thank you councillor
miss blackburn
councillor had said you have a shorter
time to reply but please do so thank you
you thank you uh i'd like to start uh
with
council evan's uh illegal levels
of this and that that's the point this
it isn't just taking
incidents in one isolation they've taken
over a fixed period and as you will know
your government was taken to court for
failing to comply with that this isn't
just like one or two
it's actually over a few year period and
it's not only it is only by introducing
this plan
we can reach compliance as directed
by ministers your ministers directors to
do this and that's absolutely clear
so you might be shaking your head well
that's actually facts council evans
your government was taken to court now i
can only uh come
again about retrofit you've been told
time and again but you simply are not
listening
we've said it it cannot cover all
vehicles not
and never was designed to but an
increasing number will be
coming over the next few months it's a
new technology it's been there for other
types of vehicles but
for the light vans it will be coming and
more will be done
but of course in as i said earlier it
will not produce four vehicles and
obviously
for older vehicles people will have to
take a judgment whether they go
for actually a replacement vehicle or
they go for a retrofit
so that's you know they have to make
that decision and i think it will
we give support and what if you want to
really help with this i suggest you
contact your government
and actually help us with the hardship
for a number of people have mentioned
this today
and that's going to be crucial to this
with that hardship fund if that's
increased we can help many more of the
drivers you just mentioned
so please do it and please lobby them
if i could concentrate on next on
councilman brophy
yeah i mean uh we cut we can only do as
we've been directed by government on on
this center it
so we are introducing cassie's scheme
because that will actually bring
compliance in the shortest possible time
by including other types of vehicles it
will not bring compliance
any quicker so therefore it we cannot we
have not been directed to do that it'd
also be another ask
on the amount of money we got to
actually uh do all the replacement
vehicles and retrofits
it's another ask on that which we cannot
do it has also impact on other
businesses and people
so i think the reality is this one it
does not bring compliance compliant
any any quicker so therefore it it it
opened to legal challenge on that one on
councillor cogging yes
we agree about hardships can you can you
sum what we really are on
the number now yeah okay right i'll try
and cut to the chase and monitor them
uh on council morgan and i think also on
uh council blackburn yes we agree on
both those points about the m60
but as you fully know the gmc tfgm
and ourselves have actually lobbied to
include the m60 and it's your government
that i simply refuse to actually accept
that that's quite you can shake your
head if you want well that's actually
facts i will tell you that
that's absolutely clear just to
concentrate on one more on
council freeman thank you for your
comments there i'd simply say obviously
we have got the exemption extended by 12
further months to actually help
develop that secondhand market and to
give other vehicle types time to
actually
do what is best whether they want to go
for a retrofit or replacement vehicle
and we've lobbied for those and we've
got those that's actually realistic we
are doing our bit
to actually help with this but we asked
the conservatives if you could please go
away and lobby your government to give
us this support to this the plan is
coming in
and it's health benefits first and
foremost i'll shock some money when not
one conservative member
mentioned the health benefits tonight
begrudgingly tonight that's right
mentioned it really needs to yeah and i
am finishing up i'll say because it's
all i think if you really want to help
us
support this this is your health benefit
i suffer from asthma too i live closely
for ticks
sure it will bring health benefits thank
you thank you councillor i'd said
we're going to move to the vault it's
been moved and seconded
the report has been moving second
and we're going to do a recorded vote so
other show vans all those in favor
please show
okay hands down all those against
okay um abstentions
okay thank you everybody um
can we have those figures please ian
thank you ian so the recommendations are
carried the recommendations are carried
and can i say to members we did move a
few meetings about that you would
address me as mayor or chair
i know people have got the habit of
calling me mr mayor
but we are trying to learn a new way of
doing things so
i would ask people i'm not going to tell
you off but i would ask you to call me
mayor
or chair thank you item number eight
revenue budget the council is formally
required to approve the addition
of public health monies to the revenue
budget as referred
from the executive meeting on the 26th
sixth of july
and i invite councillor russ executive
member for finance and governance
to move that now councillor ross thank
you mayor thank you for that
reminder there i think i needed it um
this is pretty self-explanatory there's
a minor increase in the revenue budget
down to a
late change in the financial settlement
for public health this year
so i'm happy to move and hope hope the
council approves thank you
thank you councillor ross is that
seconded just seconded thank you mayor
thank you councillor hines do any
members wish to speak to this item
or can it be agreed
you are perfectly able to speak if you
want to and nobody does so can i take it
that has been agreed aye
thank you that's been agreed item number
nine
please can i invite the executive member
for finance and governance to introduce
the treasury management
annual performance report which has been
presented to accounts and audit
committee
and the executive councilor ross thank
you mayor in the interest of time and
given that this was discussed at
accounts and audit and at executive on
monday
i am happy to propose that we note this
report
but also thank our in-house team for
their hard work throughout this year
thank you any members wishing to speak
to this item
okay if there are no further comments i
ask then for the the report to be noted
that report is noted thank you item
number 10
i invite councillor ross executive
member for finance and governance
under which portfolio responsibility
lies to introduce the report
thank you mayor um i'm delighted to
present the year-end corporate report on
health safety and well-being
this year has been a year like no other
dominated by covid related work which
has included
advice on working from home for our
colleagues
marking making our buildings covert
secure assessing the needs of staff at
greater risk of covid19 supporting our
test and trace team supporting our
schools
and providing wellbeing support
throughout the pandemic
we're not providing the usual
comparisons as uh previous years because
this year has been so
unique in the way that we've been
working but finally i would like to
place my thanks on record to our health
and safety team who have met
the challenge remarkably well given what
they've had to face this year so thank
you very much
thank you councillor ross and i didn't
actually read out the title of item
number 10 just to remind everybody
year-end corporate report on health
safety and well-being
any members wishing to speak to that
item
that report is for information can it be
noted please
hi thank you item 11.
item 11 is the accounts and audit
committee's annual report for the 2021
2020 2021 and i will invite the chair of
the committee
councillor brotherton to introduce the
report councillor brotherton
thanks chair i asked the council to note
the report
obviously it's been a difficult year for
accounts like for everybody else i'd
like to thank
the other members of the committee and
particularly the financial officers
uh and other officers for the help
during the year so i hope members could
just not the report chair
thank you councillor brotherton the
report is for noting is that seconded
please
council lied second in that report do
any councils wish to speak
report the report is for information is
it noted
hi thank you item 12
motions this evening four motions have
been listed on the summons
in the order that they were received to
get through the business and to give
everyone who wants an opportunity to
speak
it may be necessary to limit the time
for speeches
motion 9a the first motion concerns the
proposed cut
to universal credit and is to be moved
by councillor acton please
counselor acton
thank you chair i'm really pleased to
be able to move the motion before us
tonight
there are five and a half million
households in the uk
who claim universal credit
and all of those will be affected by
this change if governments scrap
the 20 pound a week uplift
which they have shamelessly announced
they will do
households in trafford and up and down
the country
will face an annual income loss of
one thousand pounds a year that
is a massive amount when you are on
a low income joseph rowntree
foundation has reported that withdrawing
the
twenty pound uplift would mean plunging
half a million people which include two
hundred thousand
children into poverty with single parent
families
suffering the most it's clear to me
that even with the existing 20 pound a
week uplift
individuals and families are already
struggling
to make ends meet and to withdraw the 20
pound
uplift will be in my view
a cruel reckless measure that will have
the effect of throwing
people over the financial cliff
and that is something that i don't think
any of us
would want to happen and this act
flies in the face of the prime minister
and tories who claim to want to level up
those people whichever whatever that
means
who have been left behind by the tories
this single act
shatters that claim this will
create unbelievable hardship
for many many people and many in this
authority and i ask all members to
support
the motion thank you chair thank you
councilloracton
is it seconded comes for thomas thank
you mayor
i'd like to second this motion because
in march 2020 in response to the
unprecedented loss of earnings
for those in work but furloughed and for
those who had lost their jobs due to the
pandemic
the government decided to increase the
basic standard allowance
of universal universal credit by 20
pounds a week
this meant instead of receiving a basic
allowance of just
74 pounds a week on universal credit
a single person over 25 would receive 94
pounds a week
and a couple 137 pounds a week to live
on
they did not increase the benefits of
disabled people
or of the carers just in work benefits
this was clearly a vote-winning strategy
to palliate the shock
of those losing their regular earnings
who had to wake up to the harsh reality
of our inadequate benefit system
after 16 months in lockdown with the
return of
freedom the government have now decided
to cut universal 20
credit back by 20 pounds a week in
september to bring it back in line with
legacy benefits
to justify this savage reduction in
people's incomes
with many many in recent media
interviews saying that this 20 pound is
their weekly food shop
the government say the focus now must be
on getting people back to work
even though many claimants are already
in work albeit at the women's sporadic
low paid or zero hours work rather than
work
with the fair wage and the fair
conditions that people deserve
not only this there's also been increase
in domestic violence
leading to single parent incomes and
increasing mental health problems
and increasing health conditions that
restrict people from working
full-time and now are restarting
evictions
with many using this extra 20 pounds
towards their rent
there can be absolutely no justification
at any time
for cutting people's working incomes or
anyone's incomes
to less than an acceptable standard of
living
below the poverty line let alone now
when goodness knows what's going around
the corner
i thought we lived in a civilized
society the fifth richest nation in the
world
please support this motion councillors
we need a benefit system that's fit for
purpose
a genuine safety net for those who
through no fault of their own
lose a job reduce their earnings or can
no longer
no longer work due to their health or
their situation
mainly maintaining this 20 pound
increase counseling would just be a
tiny step last sentence just a tiny step
towards this outcome
removing this 20 pound top up is simply
punitive
and hurtful to those people in the worst
conditions
thank thank you councillor thomas
councillor brophy
in the interest of time i'll be very
brief other than to say the liberal
democrats are supporting this motion
but i hadn't realized i was meant to be
speaking so hopefully
other speakers will have more time thank
you councillor brophy i understand
there's a conservative member who wishes
to comment
councillor evans
alec we won't be supporting
uh this motion um it's an off-the-shelf
labor motion doing the rounds um
and we won't be supporting it thank you
councillor welton you want to comment
yeah come in councillor wilson yeah
thank you very much um just um briefly i
fully support uh this motion i just
think it's a bit of a shame when
the green party had a motion down on
universal basic income which is one of
the you know the alternative strategies
that could deal with a lot of these
problems that were being discussed
within this motion um we brought that to
council tonight
only to be faced with a wrecking labor
amendment
that made it pointless and basically
reducing it down to something that just
wouldn't be bothered to be
discussed and i think if we bring this
in our ubi motion back
in september i hope it will be treated
with a bit more respect thank you very
much
thank you councillor welton councillor
wright like to comment
thank you chair let's bring some reality
to this debate into members who are
seriously thinking about voting against
this motion
this reduction will leave single people
over the age of 25 with 73 pounds
34 pence per week to live on the figures
i'm about to read out the bare minimum
weekly cost for a single person
per week in the uk in 2021
15 pounds a week for gas 15 pounds a
week for electric
seven pounds a week for water six pounds
a week for council tax
six pounds a week for broadband and 15
pounds a week for travel
what i have just read out is the
absolute bare minimum
and the most basic of human needs what's
missing
food and after those most basic of costs
not taking into account anything else
such as someone who has the audacity
to own a basic pay-as-you-go mobile
phone
you are left with 10 pounds a week to
feed yourself
10 pounds a week if you vote against
this motion that is what you are voting
for
you are voting in favor of someone
unfortunate or unfortunate enough to be
out of work
to have 10 pounds or less to spend on
food a week
and people wonder why we have food banks
in the uk
in 2021 it's a scandal
and and this government and anyone who
supports it
should be ashamed of themselves thank
you chair
thank you councillor right anybody else
wishing to speak counselor acton has the
right to reply
counsellor carr
thank you chair i just want to reiterate
and agree with my counsellor colleague
what this actually means to some
households we already have almost 50
of children living in poverty in parts
of our borough
this means people skipping meals it
means parents going hungry to feed their
children
it means children wearing hand-me-down
shoes that don't fit stuffed with
newspaper
rather than being able to afford new
shoes residents not being able to afford
birthday gifts or christmas gifts and
going into autumn and winter
having to choose between paying rent or
heating their homes
i urge all counsellors to have some
humanity
and support this motion thank you
councillor carr i'm going to ask
councillor acton to reply now
thank you chair i think just to counsel
councillor evans and the conservatives
you won't be supporting
this important motion and say that this
is an
off-the-shelf motion we'll tell that to
the 200
000 children that move into poverty that
it's off-the-shelf
motion it is not it is serious political
information and debate that we should be
having
because this is absolutely shameless
and i think you should be ashamed of
responding in that way
[Music]
and the green motion that was mentioned
you actually withdrew it we didn't
withdraw it and what we're saying
actually within the amendment is that
there should be a minimum income
guarantee
and i think that is fair and what we
should be doing
and i think that this motion is probably
the most important motion that we've
spoken about to tonight or will be on
the agenda tonight
and you know i just hope that the
government
does see sense if until september to see
that sense
and actually withdraw their proposal
thank you
mr mayor not mr mayor chair
thank you councillor actor and i'm going
to move to the vote all those in favor
of the motion please show
all those against
thank you and any abstentions
can we have the numbers ian
that motion is carried that motion is
carried thank you everybody
motion 9b the second motion this evening
regarding labour's
children's recovery plan is to be moved
by the deputy leader of the council
councillor heinz thank you
mayor as a parent of teenagers i know
the challenges young people have faced
through the last 18 months i've worried
about the disruption to their education
social world and ambition for their
future
we all know how critical childhood and
teenage years are as the building blocks
for life's chances
and and i know that actually i've been
fortunate
in that my teenagers have had workspace
their own device
and access to wi-fi that has kept them
connected not only to education
but vitally to their friends but this
hasn't been the case for all children
and the pandemic hasn't impacted all
young people equally
led by gavin williamson the government's
response for children and young people
has been woefully slow and chaotic and
this has resulted in far too many
children
being locked out of education for weeks
or months at a time
young people have struggled with their
mental health and there are many
children with additional needs
for whom the disruption has prevented
them from transitioning back into school
there are very young children whose
social development has been halted
and others who have re regressed due to
a lack of contact with the outside world
the government appointed education czar
recently resigned over the lack of
sufficient catch-up funding
stating that without a comprehensive and
urgent response
response the government risks failing
hundreds of thousands of pupils
but it's evident that there is a lack of
any meaningful plan to help children
catch up
and the lack of leadership from
governments is astounding
labour's children's recovery plan
outlines the measures that are needed to
help children catch up
and recover i do have an apology to make
actually that the labor motion
accidentally omitted labour's six pledge
which is to ensure that no child
goes hungry it's shameful that the
government attempted to abdicate its
responsibility towards the children
living in poverty in this country we
have one chance to put this right
or risk the future of a generation and i
urge all members to support this motion
thank you mayor thank you councillor
hines councillor carter
is going to second the motion councilor
carter
thank you mayor our children and young
people have paid the price for this
pandemic
and in order to keep us older people
safe the children have missed nearly a
year of schooling
a year of learning playing socialising
and keeping
safe and the pandemic has thrown into
sharp relief
many of the deep inequalities that a
decade of conservative government
has embedded into our society our
economy
and sadly our education system
all of us who govern in schools will
know that in trafford
we couldn't have done any more to
support our children
but they've been constantly let down by
the government
so much so as councillor hines has just
said
the government's education catch-ups are
sir kevin collins resigned
in protest over the prime minister's
scale down recovery plan
the 1.4 billion announced is the
equivalent of 22 pounds per child
in the average primary school and in his
words he said this betrays an
undervalued
of the importance of education and that
is why i
am supporting labour's children's
recovery programme
we cannot risk failing hundreds of
thousands of pupils
who will be affected for years to come
in trafford i am proud of our efforts to
support schools to open for the key
worker and vulnerable children
how we supported home learning we
provided 5 000 free schools per week
for families who needed them in the
school holidays and we did this because
we will not have hungry children on
our watch but this government doesn't
care
through the gmca we are putting in a
program of mental health support for all
high schools who opt into it
and individual schools and academies are
instigating their own recovery programs
as we can't rely on the government to do
so we need a fully funded programme that
supports children's
educational outcomes their well-being
and their socialisation
to give back to the generation of
children and young people
who have sacrificed so much for us thank
you
thank you councillor carter councillor
minis you'd like to comment
thank you mayor and so
having been a parent throughout this
pandemic i can say that
with the all children were affected
and all young people that were going
through education
we've had lots and lots of i think
children of
from all families have been affected
emotionally
but then we've got divisions between
families of varying wealth and ability
to teach their children
and it's been very very much laid bare
in these lockdowns that we've had in the
school closures
we had families where the parents were
furloughed and had the time to help
their children
but they didn't have the resources
they've had the parents with the
resources but limited time
due to working especially key workers
where you where schools allowed one
parent
if it had one parent key worker you
weren't allowed to send a child in
school the wealth divide got much bigger
the schools are where we bridge that gap
where we allow
social mobility for children to not be
necessarily held by what families
they've come from
this is so important it's where
libraries where
schools play their part and what we need
is now i think these divisions are going
to be
very very deep for a lot longer than
people think
and for this generation of children and
i think that any help
quite frankly most welcome it to bring
all of these young people back to where
they need to be so we will be very much
supporting this motion thank you very
much
thank you councillor minis and they
understand the conservative member
wishes to make a contribution
councillor miss blackburn
uh thank you can i just say something mr
mayor you are our first citizen
and as such i'm proud to call you mr
mayor and unfortunately i can't call you
anything other than that
thank you thank you
as a retired teacher of both mainstream
and scnd
pupils and a school governor of over 15
years
i've always had a huge interest in the
whole education of our children
and young people i know only too well
that there are individual children and
several within a family
that even in the best of times require
much more help than others
and that is especially so over this last
practically year and a half i am pleased
to see
that our governments are increasing
primary school
funding to four thousand pounds per
pupil this year
and with five thousand one hundred and
fifty pounds
per secondary pupil as part of a 14.4
billion
three-year investment it is also
investing
an additional 730 million pounds for
children
with special educational needs
our government is determined that no
child will be left behind
in their learning as a result of the
pandemic
and have so far committed a total of
three billion pounds
to catch up support as part of its
long-term
education recovery plan which includes
high quality tutoring i hope
for those who most need it at least 2.3
billion pounds
of the 33.9 billion
pound funding boost the government is
giving to the nhs
towards mental health support which is
obviously
going to be very much needed this is a
government who cares for our young
people
and wants the best for the future
as we do because most of us here are
parents and grandparents
now unlike the front bench of the labour
party in westminster
the conservative party do not consider
the coronavirus pandemic to be
a good crisis to exploit thank you
thank you councillor miss blackburn any
other members wishing to speak to this
item no councillor hines you have the
right to reply
sorry councillor hartley yeah
please
take the mic councillor hartley please
thank you i urge your members to
to support this motion council blackburn
made much of the
the government's capsule support that
have been that has been funded but
most of that is is online provision and
i wonder how many children
in care homes have access to their own
device to access the online provision
and i wonder um what happens to those
children who can't dial into that online
provision
who can't engage with the online
provision the conservatives in this
chamber in government
don't care they've done the usual thing
of contracting the job out to the
private sector
who gets paid regardless of whether the
child turns up or not the provider still
gets paid
if um and we've you know so if the
conservatives
in government are serious about children
who have fallen behind
we wouldn't have seen them support a
cutting universal credit tonight which
they should be ashamed of
so now we know mr mayor what leveling up
really means thank you
thank you councillor hartley and
councillor hans you do have the right to
reply thank you
yes um thank you may um
so i am pleased um that we've had
support
from councillor minisk tonight um
and i'm somewhat relieved i guess that
we haven't had
um an outright um opposition
from the conservative group um to this
motion
having heard um the items that they have
spoken
in opposition on um in opposing
um in opposing a plan to
tackle the housing crisis a plan to
tackle poor air quality um and
a request to main that maintain the 20
pounds
top up to universal credit and i was
expecting that they might actually
oppose um
the proposals for um labour's
recovery plan for children and i didn't
actually hear that but what i did hear
was um them extolling the virtues of the
catch-up
proposals um that have been put in place
by the conservative government and those
proposals
are nowhere near um sufficient and if we
do not go
a whole lot further than that then we do
risk a generation to come and as i said
in
my um opening remarks we only get one
chance to do this we can't
do it over and the government government
response is nowhere
near enough so i urge all members to
support the labour
motion tonight thank you mayor
thank you councillor heinz i will now
put the motion to the vote
by a show of hands all those in favor
please show
and
okay hands down and those against
thank you and any abstentions
no some of the figures ian
thank you the motion is carried the
motion is carried
motion 9c the next motion concerns the
sewell report and is to be moved by
council london
please council london
council london we can give you a little
bit more time so um i know you've
requested a little bit more time so
um thank you a chair and uh also thank
you to council western academy with us
this evening i know he was down
originally to propose this motion and i
know it's a
topic that he feels very strongly about
for those of us in the chamber and the
many trafford residents whose quality of
life
is intimately linked to racial
inequality
the publication of the seal report on
the 31st of march
was a very important occasion the black
lives matter's protest across the uk in
2020
led the prime minister to establish the
commission on race and ethnic
disparities to review and i quote
inequality in the uk
focusing on areas including poverty
education employment health
and the criminal justice system we were
hoping
chair that the commission would provide
a report into the now
incontrovertible evidence that shows the
deep seated nature of racial
inequalities
in the uk in various walks of life
and the impact that structural sometimes
known as institutionalized racism has
instead chair with this report the
government has presenters
presented us with a really poor piece of
scholarship
not my words mr mayor but those of
oxford psychiatry
professor camel deep bu who provided
evidence to the commission
and why does professor bu and some
others come to that conclusion
the reason is and i quote from the
report itself so this is the report
speaking
we found that most of the disparities we
examined
which some attribute to racial
discrimination
often do not have their origins in
racism
most however the report goes on to note
that some communities continue to be
haunted
by historic racism haunted
which is creating deep mistrust and
could be a barrier to success
that's a clear message to those of us in
the chamber tonight
who are from ethnic minorities that your
lifelong experience
many most all of racism
it's not actually about racism you're
just being haunted
haunted by historic injustices in the
past it's not real
it's not really there imagine being
spoken to like that i can tell you what
my wife
said when she heard me read that out
today my wife of
asian ethnic origin
now i could if i had time go through
each section of the report and highlight
the many academics
who've been deeply critical of its
findings unfortunately i don't
so let me focus quickly on health
inequalities we talked about this
back in march when we proposed a and
successfully proposed
the motion on social and economic
justice
professor sir michael marmot whose
leading working health inequalities at
the university college london
london's institute of health equity has
also been highly
critical of the commission's report and
he actually quoted him
this is what he said after the report
was published in his um
recent article much but not all of the
excess
of racial inequality can be attributed
to living in deprived
areas much but not all
crowded housing and being more exposed
to the virus at work
and at home these conditions are
themselves
the result of long-standing inequalities
and structural racism
he was talking specifically there about
the impact of colvid on ethnic
minorities
i also want to mention the glaring
omission of the former police
superintendent keith fraser
who was actually one of the report's
commissioners and he gave his evidence
to the commission itself and he said we
know institutional
racism exists not a mention in the
report
but he felt great reading that report or
maybe he didn't get a chance to read the
report
in the final version before it was
published as it's been alleged
two more important uh points to consider
before we start debating
firstly it tells you everything you need
to know about this report when the prime
minister's
own senior special adviser on race
samuel kasumu resigned on the very day
this report was published
lord woolley a distinguished crossbench
peer and the founding director of
operation black vote appointed kasumu to
number 10's race equality unit
and has said about his resignation the
only black special adviser in number 10
thought that his only recourse to this
grubby devices zero report
is to resign he went on this is going to
be a real
moment for the prime minister and his
aides at number 10 downing street
black people around the country are
incandescent
with rage that their lived experience of
persistent race and equality is being
denied and belittled
mr chair this report was forcibly flayed
sorry for fatally flawed from the
beginning
its commissions were only given five
months to write this report
compare that to the mcpherson report
that was only looking at the police and
was given 18 months to report
the lack of time afforded to the
commissioners is deeply disrespectful to
them
and to the many ethnic minority citizens
who were hoping for a robust set of
proposals
that could be set with a new race
equality
legislative framework for that is what
is required mr chair legislative change
if we are to take seriously the violent
persistent continuation of lived racial
injustices
in this country that the black lives
matter movement
and more recently our euro 2021 squad
successfully highlighted
thank you mr chair
thank you council london um council
arachinola's going to second the motion
thank you chair the sewer report is an
absolute disgrace from start to finish
dr begum the chief executive of the
royal me trust
said the sewell report failed on every
level
except giving comfort to the racists and
stoking the government's wall culture
culture war sorry how can sewell state
that the
term industrial races institutionalized
racism is too liberally used
and not rooted in data when the
government's own data shows that the
labor market
healthcare education and criminal
justice systems
all produce racial inequalities in
society
that black people are nine times more
likely to be stopped and searched by
police
four times more likely to die in
childbirth and five times more likely to
be excluded from schools
in 2015 a loan of 20 million
the equivalent of 17 billion in today's
money
was paid out to compensate british slave
owners in 1834
and in 2015 it was finally paid off
that means that every one of us in this
room including me
helped to pay that loan back direct to
those who directly benefit
the people who would have owned my
ancestors in jamaica
the jamaican descendants who heard the
call
to help the mother country to come and
help to rebuild britain after the second
world war
and how does this government reward the
people that came
by creating the hostile environment
legislation which tasked that the nhs
landlords banks and employees with
enforcing immigration controls which led
to win
the windrush generation and their
descendants being labelled illegal
immigrants
denying them the ability to work to
claim benefits
full access to the nhs and holding them
in detention centres
and in some tech cases deporting them to
countries
they left as a child or as or a young
adult the scandal is
far from over justice has not been done
there is a huge backlog of cases still
to be resolved
the rush the win rush compensation
scheme is a failure
it is complex and a lack of free legal
advice
and claims take months to process and
compensation
offers are insultingly small and the
policies that
led to this scandal are still in place
the hostile environment
hasn't even been suspended for the
duration of the covid19 outbreak
we did not need to waste more money and
time and resources on the sewer report
and what this government needs to do is
act on all the recommendations that have
come from previous reports
and including the mcpherson report the
public health england review of
disparities in risks and outcomes of
covid
the lawrence review the home office
review of win brush
by scandal by wendy williams and the
baroness mcgregor smith reviewing to
workplace discrimination
britain is not a post-racial society
and over and outright racism persists in
the uk particularly online you only have
to see the horrific
racial abuse the three english plays
received after missing penalties
in the recent euro semi-finals i urge
you to
use your conscience and support this
motion
thank you councillor aquinola um
councillor minis you'd like to
contribute
thank you chair
i speak with the lived experience of
being a british asian born in the uk
to a migrant family i have examples and
this is
probably going to be slightly difficult
listening possibly
are examples of institutionalized racism
and that's what i'm going to call it
because that's what it is
in the police i'm not going to say that
every police officer is racist of course
they're not
but i'm afraid it is allowed to continue
my parents my siblings are two siblings
older than me
both of them and myself have experienced
prolonged harassment by the police
across the country in different places
this report the sewell report promotes
stop and search
one of these examples my brother my
middle brother
was stopped and searched weekly for over
a year
when he lived in birmingham he wasn't
guilty of anything
apart from being brown
not as i said not all police officers
are racist
many are very helpful however
not only is nothing done to stamp out
the racism in the police
it's actually sadly encouraged by the
lack of
action this year we have seen the first
uk white policeman convicted for the
manslaughter
of a black man this isn't the first case
i'm sure we all know
of a person of color to be killed by the
police
because let's face it he did kill him
whilst racism is not as bad and as it
has been in the past and it is far far
better
i represent the war of timpali and as
everybody probably knows
it's largely majority white and gladly
obviously a lot of people are not
bothered by the colour of my skin
and happily elected me in september 2019
however
i made my first report in now at that
time i was 38 years old
of racism it's not the first time i ever
encountered it
but it was against my child and
i for the first time actually confronted
the whole issue i had the support
of many in the pub i didn't have the
support of the police
that's in 2019. so this is not something
that someone can tell me
oh you're just remembering what happened
decades ago
no someone wants to tell me i'm wrong
just try thank you thank you councillor
minis
we want to get finished for 9 30 tonight
everybody so i appreciate your help with
this
um i'm going to ask councillor merza to
speak now
he likes passing the microphone
thank you mr mayor i seek to make three
brief but important remarks in
opposition to
this motion as the first ever
ethnic minority conservative councillor
of the leafy ward of boden i'm pleased
that the government
remains fully committed to building a
fairer britain
and is taking the action needed to
address disparities wherever they exist
dr sewell and the commissioners
conducted a detailed
data-led examination of inequality
across the entire
population they have set out a positive
agenda for
change the report made 24
recommendations in achieving the four
broad themes of building trust promoting
fairness
creating agency and in achieving
inclusivity it is now absolutely right
that the government considers these
recommendations in detail
and assesses the implications for future
government policy
so that we can meaningfully address
disparities
and the inequalities in the most
effective way
i therefore joined the prime minister in
thanking dr sewell and each of the
commissioners
for generously giving their time to lead
this important piece of work
i commend the report and i oppose this
motion
thank you councillor mersa councillor
patel
thank you chair what a terrible missed
opportunity the sewell report is
a chance to reflect the life-limiting
impact racism has in the uk
just thrown away discrimination and
disadvantage in all aspects of life
evidenced within the report on a
structural scale yet that was ignored
and downplayed in the report's
conclusions and recommendations
many of those involved in the
compilation of the report were dismayed
at its final draft
phil misled and misrepresented most are
now distancing themselves from it
numerous respected organizations from
across the public and private sectors
have outlined how and why it falls so
short
as councillor london notes the
resignation of samuel
kozumu number 10's most senior advisor
for civil society and communities on the
very day
the report was released speaks volumes
over recent years races seem to be
emboldened
we have we face a growing threat an
influence from the far right
public debate has polarized and is often
poisoned with hate and racism
what we need from our government is
leadership and leadership means doing
the right thing
uncovering uncomfortable truths
politically inconvenient truths and
facing them
instead we get the political spin of the
sea welsh report and a government
leading from its front bench
on the vicious culture wars that are
ramping up tensions and causing further
division
thank you councillor patel councillor
taylor
thank you chair the school reports
claims that the uk
no longer has a system rigged against
minorities
it seeks to ignore the reality of racism
in the united kingdom
and its authors appear to be in denial
of racism and its pernicious
and damaging impact on society the
reports claimed that the uk is not
institutionally racist
and not borne out by the evidence
depressingly
racism is flourishing in the uk and its
denial
in the report effectively gives racism
and racism
the green light look at the statistics
of stop and search
and the statistics of the number of
black and uh
others from ethnic minorities within the
judicial
judicial and prison systems look at the
stephen lawrence murder
motivated by racism 28 years later the
perpetrators
have still not been brought to justice
look at covert mortality
public health england has demonstrated
that those from asian
and black ethnicities had up to 50
percent
higher risk of death when compared to
right white
british populations and look at the
disproportionate mortality and morbidity
in non-white british nhs frontline
workers
look most recently at the disgusting and
appalling abuse
levelled at three black footballers
after the euro 2020 final
and the uk is not institutionally racist
the sewell report is deeply
disappointing divisive and a wasted
opportunity
and sends out a message that this
government does not want to deal with
racism
baroness doreen lawrence states that
he's pushed the fight
against racism back 20 years or more
this government must reject the findings
of the soul report
and acknowledge that structural racism
does exist
and it is deeply damaged damaging and
legislate for a race equality act
at the earliest opportunity i urge you
all to support the motion
thank you chair thank you councillor
taylor i'm going to give council london
a minute to sum up because we want to
get the vote in it's we've got two
minutes left
sorry council dagnell i can't fit you
and apologies for that
that's a long one you've got a minute to
sum up um uh thank you to
all those who have spoken this evening
in support of the motion
i work in a very diverse school and
it's in charlton in fact it serves some
of the the residents of trafford
and go and speak to the young people
there i say to my conservative
colleagues
and speak to them about their lived
experience their day in
day out experience and ask them
well they actually know what
institutional racism is which
is more than can be said of the the
conservative party
they fully understand it because they
live it day in day out
they know how it impacts impacts on
their life whether it's being
stopped and searched by the police
advent item
for no reason they live it they
understand it
i ask you go and speak to them go and
speak to people who suffer these
experiences day in day out
what can we expect mr chair what can we
expect from a party
that's led by a prime minister that uses
phrases
about muslim women and black people that
are so offensive
that are so offensive and let's call it
out racist
what can we expect from such a party
thank you council london i'm going to go
to the vote
very quickly all those in favor of the
motion please show
thank you everybody you put your hands
down all those against the motion please
show
thank you any abstentions
no abstentions i think i can say that
motion has been carried that most has
been carried
um the last motion has been withdrawn
we've we've agreed that and i will
con close the meeting at 9 30 precisely
thank you everybody and i hope you
enjoyed the rest of your
going to evening